au terme de 3 semaines de conflit
maintenant ce sont encore les les
infirmières qui font la une de
l'actualité de ce soir à l'appel de leur
coordination elles ont manifesté cet
après-midi à Paris et dans plusieurs
villes de France à Paris elles étaient
entre 13000 à défilé selon la police
20000 selon les organisateurs de la
manifestation et pourtant la nuit
dernière les syndicats exceptions fait
de la CGT avait accepté un protocole
d'accord portant sur les augmentations
de salairirees mais visiblement cet
après-midi donc les syndicats
minoritaires dans la profession il faut
le savoir ont été désavoués par les
infirmières qui entendent ainsi montrer
qu'elle continue leur combat
[Applaudissements]
alainbeski atmosphère bon enfant mais
bon enfant en colère des chansons il est
question de Monsieur Evin ministre de la
santé des slogans du genre notre colère
n'est pas un feu de paille elle ira à
son terme et puis surtout cette
accusation les syndicats sont contre
nous
les infirmières les aides soignantes
étaient dans la rue un peu partout en
France pour réclamer je cite un
véritable statut une reconnaissance de
leur profession les salaires passaient
en second
plan on parle de revalorisation de la
profession il n'y a rien nu au niveau de
la revalorisation j'insiste là-dessus il
y a simplement eu une manne de quelques
de quelques de quelques francs qui a été
distribué de quelques francs ou
centaines de franc qui été distribué
pour faire taire les gens et pour mettre
l'opinion publique contre nous on défend
notre statut et notre formation avant
tout
faut que ce soit apolitique c'est un
mouvementolitique un mouvement
corporatiste sign les syndicats C nu à
votre avis c'est ridicule je pense qu'il
ne sont pas allés suffisamment loin dans
les négociations avec Monsieur pour vous
la l continue pour nous je pense que la
lutte continue à partir du moment où
statut et formation toujours
pasonnu d'autre part il faut pas oublier
que les syndicats ne représentent que 7
à 8% notre profession enteè desnalités
comité Deen professeur lon Schenberg ou
Joë Koffman en province comme à Paris
des infirmières lançai des appels aux
usagers pour qu'il les rejoignent ici à
Bordeaux par exemple à Lille plus de
2500 personnes étaient dans la rue un
peu partout il faut noter une forte
participation des aides soignantes leur
sort est lié à celui des infirmières
diselle